buenas tardes sin duda es un pacto una
alianza histórica que aunque cierto Noe
liderada por los grandes productores de
petróleo del planeta se ha dejado hoy y
ha expresado su voluntad política para
acabar con uno de los pendientes en esta
carrera por salvar el planeta y es ir
acabando con la producción petrolera y
de gas con hidrocarburos en general de
hecho los países firmantes han expresado
su voluntad política es bien importante
eso para incluso no seguir dando
licencias ni buscar más campos
petroleros en sus territorios como
mencionaba lo han firmado 12 regiones y
países entre ellas Francia Suecia y la
República de Irlanda también la idea es
empezar a caminar hacia esa palabra cada
vez más evidente y notorio especialmente
aquí en Glasgow a estas energías
renovables la ministra de Medio Ambiente
de Costa Rica Andrea Meza quién ha sido
uno de los cerebros de esta alianza más
del petróleo y del gas ha dicho que
espera que poco a poco otros países
empiecen a sumarse a esta iniciativa
mientras que el ministro de Medio
Ambiente de Dinamarca ha dicho que al
ser uno de los grandes productores de
petróleo de Europa está ha sido una
decisión absolutamente costosa para su
país pero qué es importante dado que no
hay un planeta B